Thanks to Curiosity Stream for supporting Crash Course.
In 1965, a brave and dedicated group of people
were a part of one of the greatest non-violent
Civil Rights demonstrations in U.S. history.
Led by Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr., the march
from Selma, Alabama to the state capitol of
Montgomery was a turning point in the fight
for voting rights.
The march’s organizers endured insults,
threats, physical violence, self-doubt, internal
division, and even death in the struggle to
guarantee access to the ballot box.
It took almost 60 years to bring that story
to the screen.
And when Selma finally arrived in 2014, it
was greeted with cheers and awards… along
with complaints and questions about its historical
accuracy.
As film critics, our job is to apply different
critical lenses to a film, to help us unlock
different meanings.
So critiquing a film like Selma through a
framework of history is one way to do it,
but it’s certainly not the only way to
evaluate it as art.
[Intro Music Plays]
It took nearly a decade for Selma to get made.
The film’s producers worked with a number
of directors and sought funding from a lot
of sources before they hit upon the perfect
combination of talent and vision in Ava DuVernay.
As a woman and a person of color, DuVernay
stands out among modern American feature filmmakers.
She had only directed two small independent
films before bringing her unique perspective
to Selma.
And, in fact, with Selma she became the first
woman of color ever to direct a Best Picture nominee.
Which is… an honor, but also really depressing
because it reveals a serious lack of inclusion
in Hollywood.
The American studio system has a long history
of denying underrepresented voices positions
of power behind the camera and at the film
studios who actually decide which movies get made.
Ava DuVernay has emerged as a leading figure
pushing Hollywood to include women and people
of color a seat at those tables.
As she puts it, “There’s a ‘belonging’
problem in Hollywood.
Change has to happen.
Inclusion is necessary for survival.”
Written by Paul Webb, the script for Selma
takes place over three months as Martin Luther
King, Jr., played by David Oyelowo, presses
President Lyndon Johnson to pass the Voting Rights Act.
King: Now, you asked how you can help.
King: We want Federal legislation granting negros the right to vote unencumbered.
At the time, many state governments kept African-American
citizens from registering to vote with administrative
hurdles, intimidation, and outright fraud.
We watch as King struggles to convince Johnson
to do something about this problem, using
non-violent tactics to force his hand.
Not to mention, King is also navigating divisions
within the Civil Rights movement and his own
strained marriage.
All while he’s under constant FBI surveillance!
King’s followers try three times to cross
the now-infamous Edmund Pettus Bridge to start
their 54-mile march to Montgomery, Alabama.
During these attempts, the marchers are beaten,
whipped, tear gassed, and in some cases killed.
It's only after this brutality is aired on national
TV,  that Johnson finally sends the Voting Rights
Act to Congress and the national guard to
protect the marchers.
And the film ends with King’s speech on
the steps of the State House, along with one-sentence
subtitles explaining what key characters would
go on to do.
Selma is a historical drama, and many of the
film’s critics honed in on the history,
comparing the events and people to their real
life counterparts.
But as James L. Deutsch pointed out in The
Journal of American History, there were many
historical films released in 2014 – from
Unbroken and The Imitation Game, to Wild and
American Sniper.
And of those films, it was Selma that “sparked
the most acrimonious debates in op-eds and
newspaper columns, radio and television talk
shows, [and] the blogosophere.”
He goes on to say, “This is not surprising,
given the contentiousness that surrounds issues
of race in the twenty-first-century United
States.”
Now, used correctly, historical analysis
is a perfectly valid way to evaluate a film.
As long as there have been movies and television
depicting historical events, there have been
audiences who take them as pure fact.
So it’s important for films to get at least
some of those real life events right.
Stray too far and you can really mess up history
in people’s minds **cough cough** Braveheart
And Selma definitely does alter some history
in favor of drama at times.
For one thing, the film changes the order
of key events.
It opens with King accepting the Nobel Peace
Prize.
And we listen to his acceptance speech over
a transition to a new scene, where children
are descending a stairway only to be killed
by a bomb.
Now, both these events happened, but the film
leads us to believe they happened close to
the same time.
In real life, though, the bombing took place
more than a year before King spoke in Oslo.
Other critics point to the scenes between
President Johnson and Dr. King, suggesting
that the film doesn’t give Johnson enough
credit for supporting voting rights.
Johnson: Well Dr. King, you've certainly given me something to think about...
Johnson: ...but, this administration is going to set this aside for a while.
The film also suggests that the events of
Bloody Sunday were broadcast live across the
country, as Alabama State Troopers brutalized
the peaceful marchers on their first attempt
to cross the bridge out of Selma.
DuVernay intercuts this violence with shots
of horrified viewers in living rooms throughout the U.S.
But, in reality, the national news didn’t
broadcast the attack until five hours later.
Much of the nation did react, they just
didn’t do it in real time.
So does Selma take liberties with the facts
of history?
For sure.
After all, it’s a dramatic interpretation
of that history.
If you think adapting a novel is tough, just
try adapting reality into a movie.
How things happen, when things happen, and
where things happen in life are genuinely
cluttered and difficult to fit into a linear
narrative.
To condense all of that into a 2 hour experience
that not only makes sense but is emotionally
potent is more than a little challenging.
Which also brings up another point.
Films, even most documentaries, aren’t intended
to be a list of events as they happened, devoid
of emotional impact.
They are intended to move us, and move us
from a perspective.
Usually, the director’s perspective.
And when a film gets right as many events
as Selma does, a purely historical analysis
doesn’t seem like the most useful form of
film criticism to evaluate it.
There’s a school of thought that says the
first few minutes of a well-constructed movie
will teach us how to watch it, so we can start
by delving into those first scenes.
The film opens with King’s words spoken
over a black screen.
It’s not the booming voice of his most famous
speeches.
It’s soft, low, and almost tentative.
King: I accept this honor for our lost ones.  Whose deaths pave our path.
The first shot is a close-up of King facing
the camera in a dark room, practicing a speech,
and doing a terrible job of tying an ascot.
Then his wife, Coretta Scott King, played
by Carmen Ejogo, enters the room.
She helps him tie the ascot, and we get an
intimate view of their relationship.
The lighting is dark and the framing is relatively
still, isolating these two as they struggle
to balance their work, their public personas,
and their marriage.
In the next scene, King receives his Nobel
Peace Prize.
DuVernay now uses more traditionally heroic
angles, keeping us slightly lower than King
and craning up, making him seem larger than
life, the public figure of popular myth.
These scenes give us two different Kings,
one private – introspective and doubting
– and one public – confident and majestic.
Finally, the third scene gives us those kids
walking down the church stairs.
When the bomb goes off, it rips through the
wall, cutting them off mid-sentence.
The violence is unexpected and immediate.
It’s shocking.
Then, DuVernay does something interesting.
As the explosion blows apart both brick and
flesh, she slows the images down until they’re
almost abstract.
It becomes difficult to tell people from objects
as they whirl across the screen, crossfading
into one another in slow motion.
This extends the horror, but also suggests
that the aftermath of this kind of racist
violence will last much longer than the bomb
itself.
This third scene also underlines the main
duality of the film – the collision of private
and public spaces.
This intimate childhood moment is invaded
by a terrorist’s explosive.
And these themes show up again and again throughout
the rest of the film.
The framing of that first shot, with King
squared off to the camera, is repeated often
– from King and his aides to regular people
joining the march.
By presenting their characters boldly, unapologetically,
facing off with us, DuVernay and her cinematographer
Bradford Young reinforce the idea that this
movie is about people demanding their dignity
in the face of both incredible violence and
apathy.
This film also keeps exploring the juxtaposition
of private and public spaces.
In intimate moments, DuVernay’s King lowers
his guard and shares his fears.
These scenes are almost always shot at night,
in houses, churches, and jail cells.
In an early scene, King makes a late-night
phone call to gospel singer Mahalia Jackson
after an emotional low-point.
She sings “Take My Hand, Precious Lord”
as King gathers strength, alone, in his dark
kitchen.
Echoing that scene much later, King goes for
a midnight drive with John Lewis, one of his
youngest supporters, and expresses grave doubts
about their mission.
This time, instead of a song, Lewis speaks
about his own experience being inspired by
King and urges him to continue on his path.
Lewis: The next day, I found myself patched up, and sittin' in a church.
Lewis: Barely hold my head up, but I needed to be there. You were gonna be speaking.
This public-private juxtaposition is also
embodied in David Oyelowo’s performance.
King’s physicality and vocal cadence change
depending on his audience.
From restrained but firm with Johnson, to
soft and anguished with Coretta, and righteous
before the microphones.
This version of King is a close examination
of what it means – and what it costs – for
people of color to code switch, or change
their style of presentation to fit the moment.
That said, no space was totally private
for King, either.
At key points throughout the movie, subtitles
on the screen give us notes from the FBI surveillance
logs with details about King’s movements,
visitors, and phone calls.
It’s a chilling reminder that even his most
intimate moments are being monitored.
The examination of public and private space
comes up in scenes without King, too.
Oprah Winfrey plays Annie Lee Cooper, a character
who tries to register to vote.
She approaches the county clerk who humiliates
and threatens her, before finally denying
her application – for the fifth time!
The message is clear: public spaces in this
part of the South were effectively off-limits
to a big chunk of the population.
Political figures like President Johnson and
the George Wallace, the white supremacist
governor of Alabama, also privately struggle
with their own doubts in interior scenes – but
always during the daytime.
They have power, the movie tells us.
The question for them is how they’re going
to use it.
In the film’s climactic moments, these public
and private spaces finally collide and are
punctuated by destruction.
When an Alabama State Trooper shoots an unarmed
black man, or thugs beat to death a white
pastor from Boston, DuVernay again slows the
action.
She forces us to endure the violence and contemplate
its aftermath.
Both these acts of violence take place at
night, which the film has already coded as
private space.
But then DuVernay breaks this pattern to depict
the Bloody Sunday violence, again in slow
motion, when marchers were beaten on the Edmund
Pettus Bridge.
It takes place in broad daylight, under the
watchful eye of television cameras.
And this is where the film crosscuts between
the public violence and the folks at home
– in their private spaces – recoiling
in horror.
Even though it breaks the historical chronology,
intercutting these events completes the theme
of the movie, thrusting the usually private
pain and violence into the glaring light of
public scrutiny.
Once again, DuVernay is using the tools of
cinema here – shots, cuts, and sound – to
reinforce her film’s message in subtle and
sophisticated ways.
There are lots of other things to say about
Selma, on matters from race and class, to
gender equity and social justice.
But almost all of it can be read in terms
of this tension between public and private
spaces and the ways people inhabit them.
DuVernay brings Martin Luther King Jr. down
to earth, revealing his human struggles.
And then, in the last low-angle medium shot
of his speech in Montgomery, she returns King
to his mythic status as one of the great American
leaders of the 20th century.
While she hasn’t stuck directly to the historical
record, she has made an enduring and resonant
portrait of an American hero.
Next time, we’ll turn back the clock to
tackle Where Are My Children, a much older
film that wrestles with some surprisingly
modern themes.
Crash Course Film Criticism is supported by Curiosity Stream
where you can stream documentary films and programs about science, nature, and history
including exclusive originals.
For example, check out the Emmy winning series, "Stephen Hawking's Favorite Places."
Where Hawking takes you on a journey through the stars and around our planet
to talk about his favorite places to go. Everywhere from Saturn to Santa Barbara.
Plus, he shares his own stories about curiosity perseverance.
It's really cool. I mean... it's Stephen Hawking so you know it's cool.
Curiosity Stream offer unlimited streaming. And for you Crash Course viewers, the first two months are free
if you sign up at curiositystream.com/crashcourse and use the promo code "crashcourse."
Crash Course Film Criticism is produced in association with PBS Digital Studios.
You can head over to their channel to check out a playlist of their latest shows,
like PBS Infinite Series, PBS Space Time, and It's Okay to Be Smart.
This episode of Crash Course was filmed in
the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney Crash Course Studio
with the help of these [nice people] and our
amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.